Speaker 1: All right.
Let's go to court here from south Florida.
I will soon be in south Florida.
And it's going to be pretty explosive, I think,
Georgia.
Speaker 2: Anyway.
How's it going?
Speaker 1: It's going well.
Speaker 2: Wonderful.
So I'm going to make it really quick because
I know you want to do questions.
I got two questions.
Speaker 1: Please.
Speaker 2: One is a ideological question that
I want to ask you.
You can tackle about an nature about people
here in South Florida.
Talk about the whole difference between nationalism
and patriotism.
Yep.
And I've come to the conclusion that is very
similar, but very different at the same time.
Okay.
Your take on that.
Speaker 1: I don't know that.
Sorry.
Did I cut you off there?
Speaker 2: I don't.
I'm sorry.
I asked.
Speaker 1: Afterwards.
Sorry.
I'm not totally sure I understand the question.
Speaker 2: So I think that I was raised in
Spain.
Speaker 1: You think that you were raised
in Spain or you were raised on Spain?
Speaker 2: Sorry.
I was raised in Spain.
Okay.
I think in my idea that the difference would
be nationalism being something that the government
tells you.
You got to love the country as opposed to
patriotism being you love the country because
you love where you live.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, we feel we.
Speaker 1: Did like a patriotism versus nationalism
thing.
You know, here's the thing.
I have two thoughts on this.
One thought is, this is a meaningful distinction.
And there's something about patriotism is
not condescending or discriminatory or oppressive,
whereas nationalism can be right.
That's like one view, I guess.
The other view would be we're really just
kind of arguing about semantics and both.
And patriotism can be just as toxic as nationalism,
depending on what you mean by it.
I don't know.
I'm not really sure, to be totally honest.
I do think.
For example, in Argentina.
One of the things a lot of Argentineans will
mention to me when they come to the U.S. is
there's just so many American flags out like
all the time.
And it's weird for two reasons.
It's weird on the one hand, because it does
feel more nationalistic than patriotic, but
also it also loses, meaning when the flags
are out all the time, where like in Argentina,
people don't just tend to display flags all
the time, but like there's a flag day and
people display flags that day.
It seems more meaningful because it's a specific
day.
But also in Argentina, the people displaying
the flags aren't more likely to be the nationalist
types like in the U.S..
So.
So I do think there's definitely a difference
in the U.S. when it comes to flags, nationalism
and patriotism.
I just don't know that I would focus on the
difference between nationalism and patriotism.
Speaker 2: Makes sense.
Thank you.
That makes sense.
My other question would be.
As an Argentinian.
I got a bit with my wife on this one.
Do you aerosols or no?
Speaker 1: Yes, I do.
I yeah.
Speaker 2: Oh, okay.
I, I just had a feeling that you were more
by what you publicized, more like plant based
diet.
So I thought maybe you weren't into outsiders.
Speaker 1: I don't eat a lot of red meat,
but when I go to Argentina, you know.
And of course.
Yes, absolutely.
Yeah.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Thank you, David.
Speaker 1: Did you win the bed or lose it?
Speaker 2: I lost.
Speaker 1: It.
You lost it.
All right.
Well, I apologize.
Court here from South Florida, very, very
good.
Lost a bet.
And we can all sort of explore explore that
further